so hello everyone um my name is mati
toel it's a real pleasure to be here and
it's so great to see some many of you
for this
um next one and a half hours I guess um
in which we're going to talk about um Ai
and um the power of AI for creativity
how much of human virtuosity is going to
play a role in the future or if it plays
an even bigger role and um I'm here with
three really amazing people and the cool
thing is that they all come from
different fields of science or from
different um professional background so
this for me that I'm I'm doing these
kind of things on music conferences
usually and it's basically almost the
same kind of people so this brings a
whole different perspective even for me
on that topic and I'm super excited to
hopefully learn a lot today because they
all come from different fields and um
with that being said um I'd like the
best is probably you introduce uh
yourself and tell a little bit what
you're doing and um then we dive into
the questions and the conversation you
want to start
I start okay sure so I'm H Jennifer hza
uh I'm a postto right now so I do
research at the vit Institute as well as
the Humber University in computer
science but my background is in
Psychology uh I think that's going to be
important today because I usually take
the human perspective uh and most of the
time I look at creativity so I ask
questions about what it is how we can uh
increase creativity individually and um
since I'm now in the computer science
department I Fell in This Rabbit Hole of
Technology
uh and so my questions are specified of
how technology shapes our creative
thinking great thank you U my name is U
oler I'm actually professor at H
University in computer science and in
biology I work at the melberg center so
that's we have to thank for all these
goodies that are lying around there this
is our um Outreach Department trying to
make you happy and engaged um mik Center
is a center for molecular medicine so
I've worked in
getting Ai and machine learning useful
to understand biomedical data and so
that's what my group does that's what a
lot of my colleagues in our Institute do
to essentially un try to get
computational methods and machine
learning in the ey specifically to gain
insights into how our genome works and
how for instance uh the genome doesn't
work when you get
sick uh yeah my name is is I pasini Tani
I'm a music machine learning engineer
and a computer musician I'm very
interested in investigating algorithmic
processes in uh um creating different
sorts of compositions and also
investigating machine learning in
different uh musical applications from
uh creating sounds directly using AI to
using it as as an indirect um assistant
to help us create those sounds all right
interesting
um my first question is probably to all
of you um because we talk about ai ai
has been around for centuries but it now
has this hype and everybody talks about
it and I think music is a a good way of
like talking about AI because I guess
all of us and especially you that are
here have some sort of relation um with
with music and um AI is going to have an
impact on that so my first question is
um maybe you can answer that um from
your own perspective um what was your
first encounter um with AI in relation
to music or creativity in the broadest
sense like the first ever do you want to
start yeah that's a very that's very
interesting question um I'm not quite
sure because the more closer I got to uh
you know realizing how machine learning
is playing a role in music uh the better
I understood how early I was actually
exposed to it so um coming from the
music composition background I think it
was around 2010 2011 where algorithmic
uh machine learning algorithms started
um emerging in plug-in settings so I
think that was actually my first
exposure to machine learning in the
context of Music well plugin in the
plugins yes um
yeah sure um I think mine is actually
quite recent in terms of um if you think
about really intelligence
um when chbt came around I think it was
exactly a year ago right in November and
all my colleagues were all over it and
talking about that and I was fairly new
to this whole concept not chatbots per
se but um generative chatbots um and I
think one of the first things that I
typed in was the standard creativity
measure we were going to talk today
about um and I asked the standard
question like what can you do with the
brick it sounds stupid but it's like a
standard measure uh and it gave very
reasonable answers and I think that was
one of the the first times when I
thought okay this machine is not just
intelligent but appears to be also
creative and I think that's how my my
journey that brought me here uh started
yeah and and you now use it as a as a
tool in your daily daily life yes all
right cool o how was it with you it's
it's a while ago actually I would say
about 30 years ago when I was an
undergrad yes uh it's a long time I'm
dating myself here um when I studed
computer science I studied in alang and
n Berg and this is a university that
actually has a had a strong foundation
in what's called pattern recognition at
the time in fact they had two different
institutes for pattern recognition so
the data driven AI that we see today
instead of classical AI which was
actually more trying to get humans to
explain to a computer what they know and
represent human knowledge in some form
of database it was called expert system
and so it was separate and so I went
into this pattern recognition and
actually because I was interested in
linguistics and in speech recognition so
that's what my audio experience was was
essentially speech recognition so we
tried to at the time build real time my
my diploma thesis I think was to build a
speech recognizer that could recognize
150 to 200 words in real time that's how
far we were at the time with the
computers at the time with the models
and the data we had at the time and it's
for me of course it's like awesome to
see how far we've come in these decades
in the meantime that this is just
something like we take for granted we
take out our phone and talk to Siri
right and it just understands Us in real
time and back in the days it was uh
different even just to get data and to
have material to work with did you
follow up on that like um in your like
on your research that you did back in
the days when you like finished your
thesis um was that topic done for you
then or did you follow up and research
more and more on so no the it continued
with Biology right so I transitioned to
biology because our DNA sequence is
essentially like a book we we
represented as letters right or four
nucleotides acgt and so I then started
training machine learning models to try
to read this book and tell me what its
content was so in in in machine learning
there was an early or in speech
recognition an early application called
topic spotting so that you don't
necessarily understand exactly what's
going on but that you understand oh this
is a new space about sports or the
weather or how your phone starts to
recognize oh these are pictures of
people or Landscapes and so forth and so
the same thing these same models we
started applying in biology when data
became available through the Human
Genome Project to say oh this is
probably a piece of the genome that
codes for an enzyme that helps you to
metabolize sugar and here is a piece
that has a switch function and switches
on genes in your liver and so forth all
right can you a little bit um maybe like
there's totally like there's different
things in in AI machine learning and a
lot of like words that probably not
everyone understands
um in your daily life when you work and
when you do your research um can you
explain on that research maybe a bit
more visually um how you use Ai and what
kind of AI systems you use in that
research so to make people understand
what this AI is actually capable of
doing and then then we talk about how
this can be applied to creativity maybe
or music and so I would want to start
with one definition oh my God now it get
boring I give that clicker in case you
want to show something oh okay um so
the there are like you said a different
buzzwords going around and one thing
that I would like to just get everyone
the same pageon is uh what's called
machine learning machine learning is a I
would say a part of ai ai artificial
intelligence is a bit of a broader
concept an older concept machine
learning is essentially an are on
computer science or statistics where we
want to build systems that learn from
data so you have data available you
build a computer system that then can
actually do something useful with new
data so the classical thing was actually
reading address labels like automatic
mail sorting was one of the super early
AI systems right it's a very defined
problem and you have examples you have
humans that tell you oh this is what
somebody wrote on this letter please
computer now learn for new letters what
the address says so that it gets
automatically sent to the right place
right and so that's a classical
definition of machine learning I have
data I train my computer based on
examples what
typical examples problems look like
and then I can use the computer on its
own to do something independently on new
data that it hasn't seen before it does
it automatically then yes all right
because it follows certain rules exactly
ites you define the rules that's why it
was called often pattern recognition at
first like it tries to recognize simple
patterns like the individual letters on
your letter and puts that
together um to solve a larger problem so
it doesn't come up with like um it
doesn't have their own path of like
doing things like it's it's really
packed in a in a in a coret of rules and
um this machine Learning System that you
built or that you working with doesn't
step outside these of these rules that's
a that's a good question so the early in
early days I would say yes that was the
case that you really tried and thought
Oh especially Germans follow rules we
just need to tell the computer what the
rules are and then the computer will be
good no I mean that's not how it works
right I mean even in letters again it's
a good example handwriting my
handwriting is terrible I really like I
like I'm pretty impressed by any
computer can read what I'm writing right
um my students usually have problems too
and um so often our data isn't perfect
right I mean people might put the the
ZIP code on the wrong place or write the
last name first and then the first name
last and and do different things and all
our handwriting is really terrible and
it still can recognize this yeah yeah so
data can be imperfect and it's big issue
in in machine learning and AI
applications is bias in the data right
so uh a computational system like a
machine Learning System can only be as
good as the data that you give it um the
data is often very noisy or imperfect or
biased and so the rules aren't actually
strict rules any of these models be it
what's called probabilistic models or
now neural networks they don't work with
with fixed rules they actually
extract try to find things in your data
and then make inferences about it so
they use probabilities and say ah you
know actually I think this is 89% a cat
and 11% a dog right so it will never be
a one- one fixed decision many or almost
all of these systems have probabilities
and uncertainties to work with and now
that opens of course also a door because
that's how we get to these super super
interesting large models now that aren't
just stuck exactly in exactly what they
know and can't do anything but you can
try to get them to do new things all
right so um but like do you see any um
like there's still a human part in it
right because when you talk about
probability and like the the results
that come out of this um pattern
recognition or the the machine Learning
System that you that you work with so at
the end of the day you as a human being
have to go through the results of that
system in order to make sure that it
detected a cat and not a uh uh dog um
well it depends on your application
right I think in again mail sorting it
probably just gets sent to somebody and
you you'll complain if you got a piece
of letter that was at the wrong address
right yeah and so um what's more
important is that we understand what
these systems are doing and why they're
doing certain things but these systems
are not getting or becoming creative by
themselves so they because like that's
the thing where I want to go is like um
the thing that you work with or the AI
systems that you work with they they are
made for a certain purpose and you use
it to do research and um you don't want
them to like do things outside of um
that yeah pattern system that you so
created I'm not sure if we is these my
slides let's see I can show you a little
bit of what we are actually doing this
so that you get an idea and it's not
just an abstract thing so this I figured
we're in the Natural hisory Museum right
so this is actually a um a plant that is
used in genetics research it's a weed
it's called arabidopsis Akash maland in
German it grows everywhere that's why
it's used because you can just grow it
and it grows like wheed because it's a
weed and um it's it's a very simple
thing and it just grow everywhere
essentially and what we with colleagues
try to understand how roots of the this
model plant of this example plants
actually grow I mean many plants have
similar setup and layout of a root that
you can see here and so a root is an
organ in a plant and it has different
cell types and it has some stem cells
where the cell divisions occur and so we
want to understand what do these cells
look like and now could we for instance
understand when something goes wrong
like if there's a mutation why would the
root grow differently and not as it
normally does
and so what we can do and this is the
type of data just that you understand in
biology why are we also talking about
machine learning for instance in this
context we can sort of dissect the root
as is shown here in the individual cells
so you have a few thousand cells per
roote and each of these cells has genes
has a program like its genome does
things right so we all have a genome
almost as a hard drive in each of our
cells and different cells activate
different things to do stuff right and
so these different cell types in the
root they're doing different things
there's the xylm and flm where your
nutrients flow and signaling occurs and
you have a a skin and epidermis and so
forth and so we can get measurements out
of each of these cells so I have a data
set of several thousand cells and for
each of these cells I observe what each
of over 20,000 genes is doing so it's a
bit could almost think like customers at
Amazon right like at Amazon you have
like many many different products you
can buy here we have many many different
things that can get active and just as
like you Amazon wants to group customers
into different buckets we can group
these cells into different buckets and
try to group them together and
understand which cells have a similar
function and so then you get this
representations these pictures like this
this kind of polistic impressionist
picture there where it says epidermis
and so forth these are actually is a is
a visualization where each of these dots
is a cell and it's colored because it
does different things like different
customers buy different things and so
then we can build these computational
models actually of how a root actually
grows so we have the stem cells in the
root and they will divide and these
cells will age and perform different
functions and so with our machine
learning approaches now we integrate all
these data to have a computer model of
what a normal root looks like and now I
can use this model similar like
generative models in in music to get
that transition to say oh if I change
this Gene here would my plant still grow
normal would my 3D model of the root
looks like it does now or maybe some
tissues don't grow as well the the root
will grow faster or it will miss some
tissues completely if something goes
wrong so I can use this creativity in
the science Sciences is like we have the
same models but we we we don't want the
model to be creative in unpredictable
fashion we want to say oh if I change
this what happens and of course like you
said the human is in the loop because we
will go back to the lab and then say
well is this actually true all right
okay am do you use a similar machine
Learning System when you talk about
machine learning but like like taking
this kind of concept of like detecting
little bits and pieces in Sound and
Music learning from it and then maybe
using it in a different way for the kind
of craft that you're doing maybe you
want to tell first what kind of like
music and sound and what your approach
from to music and sound is uh and then
answer this question if you're using or
maybe the other way around and um tell
if you do a similar thing yeah well I
mean the scope is like quite High when
the scope is quite quite vast when we
talk about music but like looking at
this graph really reminds me of a lot of
machine learning approaches that we have
done especially um well just like a
little bit of background for you I have
done a lot of
uh I have spent a lot of time and
research on the topic of tber transfer
and voice conversion and what that
essentially is that you a lot of these
models you get to see them online that
you're singing through a model and a
different voice is coming out of it or
you're sending the sound of piano
through this model and a saxophone sound
is coming out for instance and what this
graph uh reminds me of is uh imagine uh
as as as you have described we are
training a model and then we are feeding
the sound of piano into that model and
this is like the representation of what
AI let's call it the way AI sees that
model and then we are going through the
space touching upon different data
points and see what kind of
transformation happens if we are just
moving in this space what kind of sound
transformation might come out uh if
you're like mutating these data points
uh that the AI has represented for us us
so um yeah so you're using that um that
sounds like like the the tools that you
described like when you sing into a
microphone and a saxophone or a bead or
whatever can come out of that so you're
using this kind of like machine learning
detection system in order to figure out
how to build the best tool for then the
artist who wants to use that in a
creative way but you're not building it
to is that the way you particularly yes
yes well I mean the
intention the the the focus of my
practice is always putting humans at the
center of creativity uh it's no by no
means trying to replace or uh trying to
make like an autonomous system that is
just doing everything by itself it's
always a new tool given to the Musicians
to express themselves in new forms and
new ways uh so that's what I refer to
when I talk about voice conversion and T
transfer okay but then you're on the
like because this is something that a
lot of people get mixed up and um the
biggest hype that we get these days is
about generative Ai and um is it going
to be a threat for artists because it's
going to replace everyone the music
going to be done with the click of a
button and all the kind of stuff what
you're doing um has in the first place
nothing to do with that right you're in
you're basically building tools um like
we come to that later I think that
generative AI is also going to enhance
creativity in Artistry and virtuosity in
some sort of way but what you are
building is something that doesn't
create music or Sound by itself it
doesn't generate music or Sound by
itself it is a a way of um enhancing
artists it's a way of as a way of
extending them to a stretch that it was
not possible so far um these systems
could be used for autonomous generation
of sounds but they cannot be you know
they cannot
utilize themselves to just generate
something without a human supervising
them so it's all about about the
intentions of the human using the system
whether it's malicious or uh not
non-malicious do you work with um would
you consider yourself first a researcher
or an
artist well I study m multidisciplinary
music studies so I'm uh constantly
moving in between okay I say do you
think that like all of these um I think
in your in your case it's mainly
researches you don't have um other
people involved like mathematicians
probably um coders and but people who
are in the the science and research
field with with your case it's more um
you need to collaborate between like
different worlds like researchers and um
developers and artists and musicians so
my question is like how do you do that
because every one of them lives in their
own bubble they speak a certain language
they and have a certain access to all
these tools and um how they do things
how do you like um get people to do the
same like to to reach for the same goal
and communicate with each other when the
artists probably don't understand what
the coder is doing and um the
researchers don't what the artists want
to do like is there like a do you have
like a certain translator within your
teams or are you doing that or how does
that work because that's what I'm find
fascinating is like most of these tools
that especially you are building um they
they involve so many different people
from different disciplines that it's
really important to to have a clear
like way of communicating with each
other well you know in this instance I'm
actually the translator myself because I
know the the language of music and
musicians as well as uh the technical uh
vocabulary for developing these uh these
system so yeah like in this situation
I'm navigating myself around and try to
uh U keep myself informed about the
Aesthetics and the the artistical
requirements of build building these
systems in order to actually translate
uh in an artistical uh context as well
as um you know striving
towards developing the systems slightly
further in a scientific manner so uh
yeah like like to be honest it's a bit
of it's a bit of a headache for myself
from time to times but um that's that's
how it's taking place do you have the
problem that um artists want to get more
creative than researchers and um because
like my experience working with like
these different kind of people some
people like to follow a strict path and
know this is the goal we need to achieve
and then if you work with artists they
if they see an opportunity to express
their creativity in a in a in a more
profound way or um kind of like be more
perfectionist because there's a thing
that they could use and um nobody has
thought of um is the create creative
part of like um building these kinds of
tool rather um in the way of achieving
these goals or is that something that
helps to get us step further yeah it's a
very interesting uh it's a very
interesting question because well the
first thing that comes to my mind as U
has explained these models are
probabilistic so it's never determined
the
outcome the outcome is never determined
so like one time you might uh interact
with these well you might send in a data
some sort of outcome will will be
resulted and the other times is
different and I think uh from the
scientific point of view that could lead
to a disadvantage because we might
actually be needing these uh these these
probabilistic model to be more accurate
but I think in the artistical sense what
I have actually seen in the Arts world
is uh artists are actually taking these
taking this indeterminism and advantage
to create a new aesthetic and using
these aesthetic to express themselves
differently and actually set themselves
apart because they are interacting with
these models they might have an
expectation but the expectation is not
met however there is a result there and
it's you know it's their iterative
interaction with that outcome that leads
them to find New aesthetical Paths and
actually what I like to refer to as the
aesthetic of unintended artifacts all
right yeah so it kind of like influences
the their way of going forward and kind
of like um enhances their creativity in
the in the same way but the machines
that you are building um are run by
people who have a a lot of creativity in
them in order to make these machines but
the machines themselves are not creative
like because you sorry I'm trying I'm
trying to like get everyone on the same
page but there's like the term
creativity we all use that and um I'm I
was like when I prepared for the panel
today I was like um virtuosity and
creativity um is there like a definition
for that term like what is creativity
and I don't know if you can answer that
too but what's the difference from
creativity to
virtuosity because um I like I I can
tell you what I thought I thought it's
like if you know your craft well and um
you go beyond um the the all the skills
that if you can play the piano you know
everything like you getting virtuos if
you know your craft by heart and you can
step outside the structures and um given
rules that are that you have been
trained on and then you're becoming a
virtuous person but um I don't know if
that's you're the creative creativity
expert here yeah yeah so I can Define
creativity yeah right um so it's
actually like there in many definitions
and they can look complex whatever but
to keep it very simple like the essence
of creativity is to generate something
that is new and useful that's the core
two aspects new and useful and both if
you think about them both are super um
dependent on a situation and definition
in the situation so my example always is
that if you uh look at a child and a
child learns that crayons also stick on
walls that's new and useful to them
because they like it and they have fun
while doing it right and we as adults
look at it and think you know it's um
what the heck um so it really depends on
on like the perspective of the person
acting as well of the the kind of like
the person or the system um looking at
the results and judging it so creativity
is nothing objective never so that's the
start um and if you think about those
systems um because you ask are these
systems creative it really depends the
answer on who you're asking but you ask
me so um I would say yes because if you
follow the definition um we see that
especially generative AI tools like chbt
like Dolly whatever M Journey um they
come up with new and if you judge the
results as useful also with useful
results so as I said at the beginning I
I asked shbt when it was super new in
November last year uh what can you do
with the break and it came up with like
a set of alternative uses and they might
not be new to the world but so aren't
the answers you usually get from humans
and it's fairly comparable as you will
see um so yeah they can be creative okay
so machines can be creative in the sense
of like what we Define as creativity
without the machines knowing what
creativity is is yeah and that is okay
that's is where the juicy part starts
right because some some researchers
would also argue or creativity
researchers would argue they only appear
to be creative but where the heck is the
difference if I ask you the same
question what could you do with a break
and you gave me answers I value those
answers I can judge them whether they
are new or useful or original whatever
um and do I know whether you are
creative or you appear creative I think
you are creative that's what we assigned
to right so if I ask a tool and it gives
me answers and I do the same judgment I
would ref infer the same being of
creativity okay so basically at the end
of the day everything that we do um we
Define ourselves it's a creative or not
like everything that we do in our daily
life and if we go do something that is
not a routine thing that we do daily
then um it's a it's kind of a creative
creativity expression that um that we do
all create task that we do exactly and
you you also asked about virtuosity and
I would say because you it's some some
form of higher level of creativity
usually right which is rare and as you
said there's a lot of skill involved so
it's a judgment which we usually spare
for for special people or special kind
of output and if we look at generative
AI right now the output that we see and
the level of creativity that we see is
very much on an everyday
basis still creative but not to the
highest levels yet yeah but that depends
on I guess machine learning tools are
getting better like the two things that
are probably or the three things that
are needed to do this is like a lot of
data a lot of time and a lot of
computing power right these are the
three things that you need and the
longer you train a model on per se your
creative thinking or whatever it is the
more creative it will get so when you
say it's not today but will it be in the
Future Okay so this I would I would
argue a little bit differently I would
say just going in this Direction with
those three things won't get us anywhere
look at look at very brilliant and
highly intelligent people they are not
necessarily more creative or ingenious
levels not necessarily um so to to be
creative as I said like all you need is
this ability to associate things to
generate ideas what makes an idea a very
good or highly valued idea is the
Judgment by the system so the same idea
can be called minor in some context and
when a lot of people agree that it's a
good idea and maybe they work on this
idea and improve it and make it big and
we call it Innovation and then it has a
societal impact to some degree so that's
then a big idea but it could still be
the same right so as these systems are
now able to create on this basis on this
like everyday level I would say there's
nothing left that we would need to add
other than the situational or the social
judgment all right so it's the still the
the human Loop that needs to be involved
in order to decide if um this is like um
a thing and a creative outcome of a of a
system or not um do you fear that um
this is going to um impact musicians and
artists because like once we have a tool
that um we defined in our society that
this is a breakthrough tool that um is
going to be used by all the creative
artists out there and um it has a lot of
like automatic um thinking in it do you
think that
um like musicians will have a problem
with that or that musicians will rather
um have a chance to be involved in the
process of like deciding what's uh
what's a tool that um has a big impact
on society or not or on the music
business music industry Artistry so um
who decides that so at the end of today
is it like um the the majority of the
society or is it like the community of
artists and musicians who um who are
going to build these tools that will
have an impact I think I mean it's it's
very difficult to answer that questions
that question it's like um again the
scope is the scope is quite vast but
what I think you know the best uh the
best way to look at it is to look at the
history because when it comes to machine
learning in the context of music I think
um we can think of these systems as uh
sound reproduction Technologies
essentially like mostly they're in the
context of music I think um as far as my
knowledge goes we can think of them as
sound reproduction Technologies and what
what happened with sound reproduction
Technologies was that whenever it was
introduced there was some
um there was some horrific just like
going around around the whole concept we
can take uh the telephone as a
technology we can take uh the record um
uh the pH phonogram if I'm not mistaken
phonogram yeah we can take drum
machines electronic music was like a big
invention by itself I mean the whole
thing is again is quite big but and but
I think there was always this fear
that this will now replace us well to
some extent you know if you want to
think about it like the main intention
was uh maybe like talking about
electronic music let's let's take drum
machine for instance the intention of
drum machine might have been to replace
the drummer but it didn't really happen
that
way yeah go it didn't really happen it
actually found uh different roots to
make different forms of music and
allowed more musicians to express
themselves in different ways if we take
uh electron like sound that is produced
electronically maybe the intention I
think you know for not for a fact but
like a good intention was to reproduce
the sound of piano for instance or
produce the sound of guitar but they
were not doing very good you know during
during the emergence in especially in
the first uh in the in the early days so
they just like found different they
formed new Aesthetics they formed new
ways of expression would form which form
new artists of course some people were
replaced but not replaced but but they
found that okay if we start tapping into
these Technologies we might actually
be able to express ourselves differently
um you know if if we think about it it
was always this idea of yeah we're
afraid of this technology and those that
ended up using it and adapting to it
ended up benefiting from it and those
that were afraid of it they just yeah
but it was mainly like I have a picture
like this is from um back in the days
when um mechanic music basically like
Orchestra musicians back in the days
they um feared that they gonna go out of
chobs and what I wanted to say is that
um back in the days there was like
always an outside power that decided
that this is now um you say like a
societal impact like this is a a a
machine that's going to be used by
hundreds and thousands of millions of
people and people who are not like
artists were not part of the
conversation so artists were left out
and there people said okay now we have
the phonograph we have the tape we have
like certain tools and we don't need any
musicians in the radio anymore we can
play the record and all these kind of
thing so what I'm and this is like a
question probably to all of you
um I want to like stress this
collaboration thing between research and
artists and all these different like you
a musician as well right and you do
research um and you know about machine
learning and all this kind of stuff do
you feel that you need to get involved
with people who actually build tools for
music that um use machine learning
because you would have the technical
knowledge but at the same time the the
music side as well so back in that days
nobody wanted to get involved in how to
like um distribute or build a photograph
or a tape recorder or whatever it is but
these days there are people who have a
certain technical skill and an artistic
skill who could Define what's going to
have the impact in the future and make
it as easy as possible for artists to
deal with what comes
up so let me think through how to get at
this you ask essentially should should
we be afraid that something like this
should people like you get involved like
in the future of like um the the tech
side of the music world I mean
so I think it's well over overall it's
good if people come together from
different sides like you you asked us
before like oh can we actually speak
each other's language and I think this
is always when new things Clash together
it's always uh part of the the cultural
shift is to actually understand what
each other is talking about and meaning
and I think here a lot of the fears are
actually about oh it's just going to
replace us because you can see what it's
able to but you might not actually see
what the opportunities are that come
along with it yeah and so um for us I
mean it's it's not just in music right
it's everywhere these generative models
for instance in in the Sciences now in
in education of course every student now
uses cat GPT to write their reports or
their diploma or bachelor's thesis and
so the question there is not to say oh
you're not allowed to do this or how
dare you do this this is not the right
thing to do it's just a matter okay how
what's a different way to actually judge
the achievement of that student like I
it makes no sense to say in the future
that oh an um a final degree a
bachelor's St is just awarded on a
written document that's just no longer
Mak sense but that's a yeah and so I
think we need to
um engage different people in the
discussion of what we want to do in the
music industry I've seen people or in
the the writer strike in in Hollywood
was the same thing people just becoming
really afraid what can these computer
models do now they can do this
regardless if we like it or not so the
question is a to get involved in the
discussion what do we want these models
to do what's allowed to do it and be
what like I mentioned with the
bachelor's thesis what's a shift now
that we just need to do because we are
entering a
new era of new abilities but isn't this
like isn't that
um like the the the thesis example that
you brought up with like jet GPT and
asking like
um it's not that there's an equal
opportunity for all the students out
there because they all can use cat gbt
the one who educated themselves on the
skill to write prompts to know how to
interact with that machine to um to know
like who spends a lot of time with that
machine that person's thesis will
definitely be better than the one who
has used it the first time so isn't it
um a necessity um to Ed educate people
and to train people um in music um on
how to use these tools and make them
understand how they function absolutely
I mean that's partly why we're here
right actually because yes we do want to
and it's super important in this era of
new technology to actually make sure
that people have access or reasonable
and fair access to these resources right
and it applies to an individual like you
say a student it applies to us um as a
society so for instance I mean we're
part of the helmholtz research center so
these are the large research centers in
Germany that actually operate the
largest supercomputers in Germany and so
we have discussions amongst us to say
okay which ones of these models do we
want to also take up and build in
Germany so that we have them available
for us as a society and they're not in
some company in California that we have
no influence over right so I think we
are facing actually as a society and
then the you luckily it's actually
really a very good example that the
parliament is taking up this idea of
what's a fair use and a responsible use
of AI yeah absolutely that's that's a
whole whole topic that we could talk for
ages it's an important topic um but um
sticking with that jet gbt example
because this is probably your main
machine that you are working with right
um like if artists like I know that
people try to write like so I'm so for
me AI is a tool in every kind of sense
um I think like if you're bad in your
craft and you want to um impersonate
someone or want to like be as good as a
painter or a musician but you would
never be able to actually learn all
these instruments and all these skills
um AI can actually help you to kind
compensate the weaknesses that you have
or um Empower your strengths so I have
friends who um who are super good
musicians but they're really bad in in
text writing songwriting and all that
kind of stuff um um and for them jet GPT
is a big big thing because it's not
always perfect but it helps them to
inspire and um to then like I don't know
when they have a writers blockade to
like um move on with that um would you
say in your like I don't know how many
hours you worked with jet GPD so far but
um You probably um talked a lot to that
machine um would you say that um from a
pure um poetic um perspective in writing
um songs that uh could touch you and um
could be emotional would a machine I'm
talking for all the songwriters out
there um um is that a possible that this
machine will be able to do
this not without very intense prompting
I would say so the and that is exactly
where the human is in a loop as we keep
saying because this machine is not doing
it like as you said with one click it
gives a lot of output but it needs
refinement because any kind of like the
if you put in like a vague instruction
what can you do with pants you get vague
answers that's the rule number one so if
you want to have like a very certain
emotional song text or something you
actually have to put in a lot of content
a lot of information to get precise
content out that's the rule um so again
I think it needs this imagination of a
human to to come up with like good
results I think it's easy to get good
enough results but you have really good
results you have to put in a lot all
right but this isn't the like if you
like I have the experience I didn't do a
lot with chat GPT but um when I
communicate with that machine um about a
certain topic and um the longer I
communicate with that machine the more
um it really gets what I mean with the
prompts that I put in so let's say um
you are a musician and you going through
a truck addiction and you want to get um
rid of that and you are asking cat gbt
what can I do what helps me this that
that and and you talk to that machine
like for days and weeks about this topic
because this is something that is like
the main focus in your life and then you
want to write a text about that and
express your feelings but you're really
bad in in songw writing text writing so
you let the machine do that wouldn't
that be a a possible outcome because
you've communicated so much with that um
okay first don't use it as a therapist
there their studies about that it's
really bad okay because it's very vague
but yes um if if you Converse a lot with
it it gets a lot of information and can
use that to be more precise exactly um
and then again it's it's it's the
question of who's the judge of whether
this output is good enough as a con as a
context I mean we also have bands who
sing la la la like for three minutes and
it's still considered a creative song
somehow by some people um so it's really
a matter of who's the
judge maybe I can chime in here a little
bit right I I read a few months ago
right Nick Cave complained because some
fans actually used chpt to write lyrics
and they were really like asked chpt to
write new song text for ni cave songs
and send it to him because they were
really excited and he was of course
super offended because like how could
this machine ever come up with something
that would come close to what he
experienced as a human being and that he
went through and we might know about his
personal history that actually led to
these song texts in the end and
so that's a valid
answer it's about you know the
essentially about the the usefulness of
the result and usefulness doesn't mean
monetary value usefulness could be that
it triggers emotions in you and that it
has a like you as a human react to
something in a positive or strong way
um the trick is however that of course
this this machine is learned on song
text so can it generate text and CH GPT
is really it's a text generator it's not
in I wouldn't actually say it's
intelligent that's the whole thing
that's why I said it's machine learning
and not artificial intelligence and the
prompt that you provide essentially
shift these probabilities that we talk
about to just generate text that's more
like from this and not that topic or in
this and not that style it doesn't
actually learn anything from your
prompts it just shifts the probabilities
in the model to give you different text
and now can that text come closer and
closer to something that's superficially
similar to Nick Cave because yes it's
also read all his song lyrics yes yeah
and so that's
the the tricky thing I think one aspect
that is also in this example I think is
that we as humans are not so special
with our emotions and feelings and
thoughts and I know that artists who
produce like you know put their own
stories and emotions in song text or
pictures or paintings whatever of course
they feel like it's super special and it
is for them in this situation but
overall we share all this kind of human
experience and it's in the data set very
well represented so of course you can
also take it out yeah but the human side
of things is still that um the emotional
side of thing because we haven't
invented an emotional machine Learning
System so um a machine can't be
heartbroken a machine can't um go
through a truck addiction a machine but
it can produce Like lyrics for example
that trigger emotions in US yes like
another artist would do so there is
again this this debate I think nudging
on now about being and appearing and I
think if you look only at output as like
a song text where is the difference yeah
I mean the machine can learn what
triggers and what doesn't trigger um
putting that from the written text words
to like the musical side of things I
guess that there's also studies and
research about what kind of like chords
work best to have like a major pop song
and what kind of frequencies work best
to kind of like um trigger certain I
don't know synopsis in your in your
brain these kind of things um have you
done something with that or any um
experiment experiments with like um
similar to the text example that I just
said like trying to let a machine um
produce I don't want to say functional
music but produce music for a certain
purpose because it has learned that this
purpose can be achieved by using XY Z I
wouldn't say uh you know again with the
example of chat GPD I wouldn't say uh
without an excessive refinement of the
prompts that you do in order to actually
make it into a usable that is resonating
with your emotions um I wouldn't say so
no but like one thing that we really
have to consider is music is inherently
um a cultural uh related uh phenomena
something that might might harmonically
resonate with me um might not do with
you or uh some members in the audience
or it might resonate with you so it's
like it's it's very difficult to encode
that well it's very difficult yet I know
for a lot of uh fellow machine learning
music machine learning researchers to
encode these cultural information into
machines and actually
generate culturally informed music which
could resonate with uh people from a
specific not I mean when we talk about
culture we're not talking this like
traditional sense that like for instance
if I'm coming from Iran I only resonate
with music that is that have been
exposed to in Iran because now we're
living in this um in the era of Internet
so we're like exposed to a lot of
different sounds and um different kind
of harmonies from different cultures but
what I do see like an interesting
application what I see is the moment
that AI is being developed well the
accessibility of developing these uh
systems will be in the hands of uh us
actually like everyone in their home can
start developing these systems within a
click on their own uh collected data
which is uh which culture well in the we
were talking about music in the
framework of music that culturally
culturally resonates with them and that
could actually lead to
um an
emotionally uh pleasing
outcome okay uh so I guess so you mean
like if if I can take my my my The
Treasure of audio and music that I have
on my hard drives and feed that to a
machine in the future it would come up
with music that would automatically be
pleasing to me because um I used to like
all the other stuff well the chances are
high you know if if we are training a
model on my playlist and then we asking
you to but if I'm listening to like I
grew up with like hip hop then went to
skate Punk then to drumond Bass then to
like um Scar reggy and Dano and now I'm
to into fun and soul so it's quite a
like it's kind of like in the same realm
but I didn't go to heavy metal or techno
but um let's add that to it as well and
then tell a machine to come up with
something that's pleasing to me I mean
as we all know a machine is not a human
being so it must be pretty confusing to
that machine to understand like what it
should come up with or not which human
being would know the answer either yeah
well when when I'm talking about you
know developing this machine it's not
like an end to end that you just like
say Hey you know come and see this data
and generate something that is pleasing
for me we're talking about series of
steps that results to the the desired
outcome so which I'm I mean it's beyond
the scope of this talk obviously and I'm
una aware of a lot of those steps at the
present time but that's that's how
that's how I actually see those Stu see
these things because um what really at
the end of the day it doesn't matter the
the methodology we Ed to create music or
create sounds or any other form of art
is has to it has to resonate with it has
to touch something in our brains it has
to touch something in our nostalgia in
our memory or I don't know some other
thing something that we might experience
yesterday or is likely to experience
tomorrow in a society that we're living
and it has to resonate whether that's so
it's like all about localizing these
models it's about so there's no General
um like because I just read a piece
about like the saddest song in the world
there's a YouTube that it's on YouTube
it's a old song I Really unfortunately
can't remember that but some researchers
have defined that this is the saddest
song in the world so it has to resonate
with like lots of people who were part
of that research I guess so if we take
that song structure and we feed it to an
AI and um I don't want to get too deep
into all of that but at the end of the
day um this is a result that humans did
for with research and it can be fed to
machine and the machine can understand
that um if this is how we make people
cry um we should prod or we can produce
more music in that sort of sense h i
mean yes actually the simple answer to
that is yes it's ultimately about how
much data you have available and just
this example of oh I would be hard to
predict because I had you know personal
history that led me through different
music
directions um yes that's partially true
but also you know there are many many
other people that Spotify learns from
right they don't just learn from your
one example from one example you cannot
learn this absolutely from many many
other humans there will be some
similarities and who like certain
seemingly distinct groups of musics and
not other ones and so there actually you
are probably more predictable than
because of all the other data from
millions of other humans than we might
ourselves think yeah and getting
additional data like um yeah how did
humans react to this and not just oh
what you you liked something but any
additional oh I liked it because I liked
it because it made me happy I liked it
because it makes me sad that's
information that will help well help
depending if you think it's helpful that
will assist
AI systems to become more and
more yeah
creative in our understanding of of this
term so at the end it comes down to the
amount of data and um like I agree with
you that um or I like I spoke to a
couple of people at stability and stuff
and um they also believed that um it's
just a matter of they say months maybe
years that we can run systems like that
on our own computers and um but but that
might be technically possible but then
we still have the problem that um we
need the amount of data and you just
said I can take the data from my hard
drive um which is that's one possibility
that I said but I could never use it in
a in a in a commercial way you know
where I want to get I want to get like
the
um the people who have produced this
music like let's say I have a terabyte
of music on my hard drive and um I feed
it into an AI and cool stuff comes out
um I could never like I could use it for
my own pleasure but I could not um like
use it for like commercial senses or um
perform it with a band and then maybe
charge tickets for that because at the
end of the day uh I took this music that
I have on my hard drive um to enhance my
own creative output and then maybe
perform it with my own band but the
people who have produced the music in
the first place who are on my hard drive
um they they wouldn't allow that because
um they they have put their creativity
and their craft into into the music and
um not to give it to me in order to like
um piggyback on their on their
creativity
basically
sorry yeah what like what what is very
interesting in this sense is that the
same people that might complain about
you you well us using other people's
data to gain some Financial benefit out
of it they might not complain if we just
like listen to that music and then go
through go through the hardship of
learning about music and Harmony and
structure form and all those requ
requirements to come up with a musical
piece and if at the end of the day if we
listen to their music and come up with
something very similar they might not
complain about it but if we like using
the machine to do it for us and just
like you know us being a supervisor
which at the end of the day it's not
really their data that's coming out of
the machine it's the in between data I
would say
because well obviously this it's like
the same thing is in most of the cases
the same thing is not coming out taking
for instance beetle beetle track for uh
as an
example if we if the beetle track is
included in the data set of a machine
that we have you know trained on a vast
Corpus of data we might not actually be
ever be possible like be capable of
extracting the beetle stke out of it
yeah we might be we might not be I don't
know the answer because we also like
talking very abstract here uh but it's
like a very interesting discussion by
itself which we can save it for later
but yeah yeah yeah yeah no no I mean
that this is how we can figure out what
data is in the song that comes out at
the end of the day um so far the people
that I talk to it's a it's a problem we
can't solve if we have like a billion of
songs and then people talk about
fingerprinting but I don't want to get
too deep into into that at the end of
the day um I like what you said like it
at the end of the day um we could learn
that craftmanship and that music that we
like from our most favorite Band by
ourselves over a period of 20 or 30
years maybe be never so as good as they
are but um we could do it potentially
and an AI just speeds up the process in
order to like um helps us have the um
desired outcome um without learning the
craftsmanship which means um AI is going
to make us lazy and um I mean which
which I think you know as human beings
we're inherently are uh you know workshy
sort of uh yeah cre I mean that's that's
I think we agree
right yeah I mean this is why why we
that's why we invent computer I mean
that's why we invent stuff B why kids
probably can't read maps anymore because
um we have this um device with us that
tells us where to go yeah so yeah I
totally agree but this uh goes uh um
it's uh not like this doesn't go well
with creativity I mean at the end of the
day you can't be lazy in order to I mean
you don't invent things in your sleep
and uh you have to have some sort of
driving impulse in yourself in order to
to be creative um do you like because
you've like you're the the expert on on
on creativity basically also human
creativity right it's not only you don't
only look for like the creative
potential of machines but also on on
human beings um do you feel with like
the access to technology and um with
tools that make it as easy as we just
talked about
um leads to less creativity or different
like I don't want to I know it's a
matter of perspective and and we had
that it depends yes yeah yeah but at the
end of the day um do you do you because
like you doing so much research do you
see like that there's um a different
kind of creativity that um um grows in
human beings through the technology and
the tools that we have at our hands or
do you think that um
people that you've spoken to that you've
done research with um lose parts of
their creative site in themselves
because um things are automated and um
they don't need to put much effort in
learning an instrument or something like
that I would say it really depends so we
see all sorts of these things right so
we see people getting lazy we have the
Googling effect right we we forget stuff
we who knows telephone numbers nowadays
like I know just my own
um and that's a fact because we have all
these kind of devices with us all the
times this access of information that
makes us lazy that's one part of the
story but on the other hand we get
enhanced in our abilities um through
technology all the time we know so much
more thanks to Google Maps and we know
now we have like a fancy color palette
with now I don't know um sparkling
colors thanks to technology um which
makes us more creative in other ways
right so maybe we get lazy in learning
instrument traditional instruments but
then we have digital instruments like
you know prompting them and learning how
to prompt is a new skill so I would not
necessarily say that we get less
creative it really shifts but there's a
big butt and that is that um the sheer
fact that we look at screens and most
technology comes in forms of of screens
the sh fact that we look at these
squares makes us less creative it's like
literally makes us look inside a box um
and that there was a very very great
nature paper about that um comparing um
Zoom meetings with like normal desk
meetings right in real life and we can
see that we we think less flexible when
we look inside a box it's depressing
because our modern world modern working
life is built so much around digitality
digitalization and working digitally um
so this there's this big butt and the
second thing is that through technology
information is so easy to access that we
are constantly overwhelmed and we are
never bored anymore and boredom is so
important for our inspiration and for
finding problems that we might want find
solutions for and you know be open for
inspiration of All Sorts so there it'ss
the other big butt all right but it
means that um if like if I am a Pianist
and I learned that um that instrument
for like 30 years and by heart and um I
reached that point where
I I'm LL I know everything so um in
order to um take the next step um to to
be able to compete like let's talk about
what's 10 20 years in order to compete
with people who um have used an a
machine a machine Learning System on AI
to kind of like give me the same outcome
than um a Pianist or maybe a Pianist is
a bad example because it's all about
performance in plain life and this is
probably a long time until a machine is
doing that but um let's talk about um
composer like I'm a a great composer I
compose some um scores for movies and
stuff like that and um I've done that I
learned that by heart and um in the
future that's probably one of the more
likely things to happen is that uh that
a machine Learning System um can also
compose scores so in order for me to um
survive that face as a creative composer
that writes these
scores I must basically learn how to use
these machine learning and AI systems in
order to be competitive with like the
folks that um have or have started this
whole career with like um
machines well in general I would say so
yes there there's this like the famous
phrase that you are not substituted by
AI but you're most likely substituted by
a person who uses AI because AI makes us
so much more efficient and and
efficiency in our world counts a
lot but then I would also say that for
every Trend you always find a counter
Trend that might be Niche or tinier in
impact and in size and magnitude but you
will find it so I think going analog and
and for me I my my prediction for the
next 10 years is that we recognize that
we actually have bodies and we we you
know um think more physically I guess um
as this counter movement um so there you
will always find those Niche but then
it's it's a question of you're the lucky
one surviving in a
niche so um I think what you're getting
at what I what I think we will see and
what we see with J GPT already is that
computers are able
to um create new or generate creative
new
output that is similar to what the
machine has already learned that sort of
this almost like there's some
definitions of almost like levels of
creativity and sort of the simplest
level is generate more things similar to
what you already knew and I think this
type of application we'll see a lot be
it music be it in the lab actually for
us too in and or writing scientific text
or be it for the screenwriters in
Hollywood this discussion the other day
and it's like yeah there there's manuals
how to write this too and if there's a
manual how to write it it was already
it's already in jbt because the book's
in there and so people will write
predictive scripts for soap operas a
computer will do a very decent job at
this and so then the question is what
new formats are there where you're not
just generating things but you're
combining things in new way you're
stepping outside we had this before like
with the virtuosity is stepping outside
your known coordinate system somewhere
else where the where things really look
and sound different these kind of things
that happened in in in art history right
when you had the first abstract
paintings or 12 tone music something
that's really different from how things
were before that's where I see
definitely machines still not being at
that point yet all right but that's
that's like the the rather boring part
of machines like replicating things that
have been already been there the example
that we had before like with my hard
drive of all the different jurus that I
have like isn't that a likely like
that's my hope like um so when I was
young you could see what kind of music
people would listen to how they dressed
like certain people tressed in certain
subcultures so I don't see that anymore
on the streets and I don't know where
this went maybe we don't have that many
subcultures anymore maybe because the
music cultures in it in themselves are
not as um present and as um yeah are not
there anymore so my question here is um
from a musical perspective would an AI
be able to create a new kind of
subculture by mixing genres with each
other that um um would create a new JRE
um and like we can take it until the
Infinity but um with that J create a
certain style a certain image a certain
um visual identity to the zap Shor so at
the end of the day an AI system like
that's my hope could create a kind of
like a movement and um a musical a
subculture that's driven by music but
has like a way broader um perspective on
on on society than just music is that a
likely thing that um we can expect from
the future like um having an AI system
as a dver for a subculture I think you
just describe Tik Tok in your your words
right because uh true yeah I mean like
Tik Tok algorithms is actually allowing
a lot of uh especially young uh younger
generation I think when I'm well between
maybe 15 16 to 20 I'm like referring to
uh they are using they are perfecting
these algorithms mostly
ai ai powered to collaborate in ways
unimaginable so far uh the the remixing
culture is just on a different level now
with a lot of music
um music uh machine learning music
algorithms like stem separation which
essentially deconstructs uh deconstruct
the sound of one uh same like a mixture
track into different parts of it and
then you can use different parts like a
piano of a track and mix it with a vocal
and then sing on top of it and then put
it out there to um express yourself in
ways or collaborate with your favorite
artist that you so far didn't have such
a privilege and like through these kind
of collaborations people are finding
each other and creating more contents
and contents and like creating these
virtual subcultures so yes of course
it's not it's no longer similar to what
was I don't want to like you know point
out any dates because I'm very bad at
those but like it's not similar to the
pun culture that was going on
uh you know in the Britain or maybe also
in Germany it's not similar to the techn
culture um but it's humans um trying to
make use of the tools in a on a in a
what is it a social media platform and
collaborate with each other from
different backgrounds different
countries different musical backgrounds
but um where I want to go is like
um like it's unlikely the example that I
said before that uh um a folk singer um
hangs out with a I don't know I'm not on
Tik to maybe I'm totally wrong now and
it's super embarrassing but I guess that
there are no folk singers who
collaborate with heavy metal drummers
and um techno producers and um rap
artists and to create new songs if
that's so then that's amazing but what
where I want to go is like um an AI can
you can give them like millions of
tracks from one sh and another sh and
another sh and would come out with a
track of a mixture of all these chores
which humans are not capable of doing
because of the digesting of that big
amount of data that's where I want to go
is that possible so you can I mean
another level of creativity is just
combine different things and of course
humans are way
more humans are less effective in
combining new things computers can of
just combine more things together right
because they're faster they're more
efficient in that way but that comes
back to the second part which is the
value aspect right it's like not any
random combination will be interesting
for humans most of it will sound like
to us and so it has no value to us
and so the important part that would
come in and also in the Sciences for
instance if we step too far outside
what's known we need some other entity
to tell us is that useful is that of
value and so this is for the music that
holds and even in the lab when we create
new DNA sequences and think will the
root now grow better if I stay close to
the original genome I know what's going
to happen the computer can come up with
suggestions that are totally far off I
have no idea if this will work maybe it
does but I need to go back in the lab
and check it if it gets too far from
what I already know yeah and the same
holds here and it's again a matter of
the data then if people give input and
feedback and information to the computer
what combinations are valuable and
interesting for whatever reason at some
point a machine and machine learning
algorithm will extract some underlying
features what last thing I want to say
is but that's also interesting and
that's for instance the science is
interesting and maybe also in the music
industry like why are certain things
then suddenly of value why do we like
certain things why does this genome
sequence now work so if I can turn this
around and use the machine learning not
just to give me some new stuff but also
help me understand our own emotions our
own reaction to this better it's cool
right I want to add something that I
think when we're talking about human
genomes we're like I mean there are Liv
at stake there if something goes wrong
correct well that's why I said plants
right yes well they life like their PL
life of the plants are at stake which
will could result to some environmental
issues later on yeah I mean we're not
you know letting this loose in yeah yeah
of course of course of course and and
there are things in the lab for instance
like we we are building or we I mean not
me at my lab but colleagues are building
like mini tissues and and trying to
replicate different parts of of your
body to effectively be able to do this
and assess it without you of course
without like trying this out on a human
right yeah no what I wanted to actually
refer to is that you know such such
failure cases um in the musical or
like a bit broader in the in the
artistical sense is actually um seen as
advantages uh rather than uh LIF staking
phenomenons uh so you know so that's why
I wanted to wanted to just like U put a
spotlight on and um yeah I
think wow I lost it all I yeah yeah then
I take over so what I what I was also
hearing here is that because I would
agree generally that usefulness is
important but what we and and random
combination is not what we want per se
but what we gain definitely by AI is uh
easy access to all sorts of information
that makes us more power ful in the
sense of com combining much more as our
brains would be able on its own um and
by that I think what you said you value
in music we sometimes in research we
call uh Serendipity so this randomness
of finding something that Sparks
actually an association or an idea that
is great and I think by by having the
computer power basically to randomly
combine more things more Styles more
data points on genomes whatever I think
we just increased this the the chance of
like successful ctivity
here so yeah in order to wrap this up
like the the last question that I have
is like um how like the question that
stands overall is here like um Can AI be
a booster for creativity and um I guess
it depends um but um how like from your
own perspective how do you think can
like now we learn so much about like
that societal Norms play a role in
acceptance of certain tools and when
it's going to work or not but how can AI
be um beneficial um for us as human
beings um in order to enhance our
creativity in the future so what would
be your dream scenario besides saying
you can train AI on your own computer
like um what what do you think like will
be the booster for our own creativity um
in the future future when everyone has
access to AI
tools do you want to start yes I I have
a vision and my vision is that first off
we get rid of texting because that is
ridiculously inefficient so first off I
want to talk to a bot and get direct
yeah it's just so much quicker is it I
could change voices of course um and and
like my dream really is you remember
clippy the very annoying you can do that
with Alexa already or not
nah no no no so clippy what's your cliy
on bird clippy on like on on in Windows
like office tool
right the what is it called like a it's
it's a clip a different name I think no
it's clippy it was clippy yes so clippy
we get clippy um but then like very
smart and it kind of like you know has
this memory of what I talk to so I don't
have to repeat my my proms again and
again but it became becomes basically my
personal assistant that's my dream so so
because I forget a lot then I won't
because I have
clippy and then what is essentially like
super necessary for creativity is that
this tool will be off for like a third
of the day so I won't be bothered by
technology that's that's the dream all
right what's your vision of like uh the
booster for creativity with AI so
there's there's the professional side in
in genetics I hope that we actually get
more creative than we are because in the
creativity we get to New Solutions and
to New Directions that we might not have
looked at because we're working a lot
with like very little bits of knowledge
that we already have and I think this
will give us totally new directions to
look into um in a my private musician
thing I'm as analog as possible I sing
on an AC capella vocal group doesn't get
more analog than this the only digital
thing is if I forget my scores at home
and I have to read them on the iPad um
why am I saying this why why do I want
to say this and it's the same as what
you said is because our brains we don't
quite understand yet how our brains and
how our own creativity is influenced by
just doing so much digital and on
screens and in boxes and you know
singing together with other people just
you know activates parts of my brain
that would otherwise not be active at
all right and so this part of why music
does even exist in evolution and what
was the evolutionary advantage of having
music that's all what it's about right
it's like music has some inherent
stimulation to the brain that was useful
otherwise it wouldn't have led to its
current state where we are so that that
actually doesn't get lost I think we
really need to watch out and make sure
that our lives maintain room for
this yeah and lastly yeah last of you
yeah well I think um it would be very
much in lines
of something I would like to call is exp
placement rather than replacement that
it just like extends you to a point that
you essentially repl replace your past
self they just like give you so
much so much room to move and navigate
that you no longer be doing the things
that you have done before it just uh
it's a very interesting times indeed um
which essentially maybe I'm just like
projecting myself onto the question but
this is what happened to me
I'm I'm no longer doing what I used to
do a few years ago but I definitely was
not uh replaced as much as I was but
it's cool like all of you had like a put
a strong Spotlight on the on the human
side of things and all you wanted to do
is basically have a like have a little
helper or an extension of um your own
brain by a machine but none of you um
talked about a machine that generates
things for you to enhance your
creativity so that's a that's a cool
thing and I think um it's a it's a
positive outlook into the future and I
think um maybe one day we are still
alive when we have one of these tools
and um it will boost all our creativity
and um yeah thanks so much for this
conversation I learned a lot and um
thanks all of you for um Coming and um
yeah enjoy the rest of your
[Applause]
evening